During back to the debate about, am I a real anime factor? But like,
cause you mentioned something, you said like, uh, V tuba is whatever anime,
manga Gacha games.
Why do you feel like Gacha games is like a big part of being an animate fan.
Gotcha. Gotcha. Is originally from Japan. From anime? Yeah.
It's Japanese kind of invented it.
Yeah, but it doesn't mean it's it's not that deep in anime culture. Right?
It's like, no, it kind of,
I couldn't be an anime fan without ever playing a Gachet game.
Yeah, of course you can't play, but it very rarely play gotcha.
Game without being an animate fan. Yeah.
Exactly. I mean,
there's plenty of original light Gacha games out there that aren't anime based
at all.
But how many people play those compared to the enemy base scout your games?
Well, I mean, well again, impact anatomy game. How has, how has ginching.
Impact no anatomy? Yeah. Well, I would consider.
Animate being like the actual, like Monga.
No, like I'm more talking about like the anime
[inaudible] lanes, the arc nights,
like they want based off anything and then same with Vichi was right.
Like I would say who's watching V tubers. Who's never watched anime before.
You know what I mean? That's, that's a confused dad watching.
I liked, I liked the gotcha games. I mean,
I've really enjoyed doc nights when I was playing that I don't really play it
anymore. Um, but like again, she was fine.
I didn't like I couldn't skip any of the dialogue. I think they added.
That. Now they've added that literally rage quit.
One of my streams because there was so much dialogue and it wouldn't have stop
and you would walk 10 seconds to get another dialogue for two minutes.
This is taking the. It's just ridiculous. No one can enjoy it.
Yeah. I want to say, I want to see you play y'all cause a game.
You probably lose your mind.
I'd be like, what is happening? What is going on? And like,
I don't get it. How people can get excited for every new gotcha game.
That's a question you have to ask.
You've been brainwashed into being excited for rates that are higher than
2%. We're like boys, boys, it's practically 50 50,
but it's practically 1%.
The bump 2% guaranteed drive. I feel called out now.
And they've all mean it so much that they're actually like proud of it when it's
like 2%, like they're practically giving the five stars away.
Like that's probably the only guaranteed draw.
Like a lot of the stuff. I've just,
I hate how games have just completely normalized. Like, you know,
micro-transactions to death. Yeah. Like I injured. It was fun, but like,
you know, I'd spent like 800 bucks on that game and they was still submissions.
I couldn't do. And I'm like,
how much do I need to spend to be able to beat like do the hottest missions?
Tell me how much.
Just, just turn your brain off and just enjoy the game.
And you'll just enjoy the experience.
Beep beep you got no resources left or do you want to pay?
You want to play a little money to keep playing? Do you?
I hate that.
I would say the only real God you gave him playing right now is [inaudible]
. And my biggest problem of Kenshin has nothing to do with like the catches
system. Even though the pull rates suck. But I mean, I never get like if, if
the, if the, if the drop rates are, then I don't go into with a
mentality of I'm going to get this character. I'm going to get this person. When you come in with X,
when are you coming in with expectations? That's when you lose, okay. That's
when you lose walking into a casino being like I'm going to win the jackpot. I
actually biggest problem with Kenshin right now is that when you reach
the end game, it really, it, it really feels like you reached
the end game because you, you, you are squid
. Like you're squeezing out content. That's just not there.
It's become so apparent with Kenshin as opposed to other gadget games.
Cause I'm sure we've played enough games that when you reached that point,
right where you, you, you, you,
you had to open it to the dailies and you're like, I've got nothing to do.
This is just this just, this is just a part-time job. I'm grinding away.
I'm just watching numbers go up. But like it's, it's,
it's less noticeable when it's a phone game, but when it, when it's on Gunjan,
cause I don't know how people play Gunjan on the phone, man. How you doing?
How you do storm terror or the Wolf porcelain get on your phone.
That's that's beyond me. But like,
it feels so weird when I got to the end game against you.
And I would log on for like an hour, a day on the PC. And I would just like,
I would just grind and I will do nothing but grind. Cause I'd done.
I'd gone through all like the, the actual content of the game. And it really,
it really feels like it's really apparent on Kenshin because it feels
like the first real Gachet game. That's like, that should be played on console.
And it feels more like an RPG. Whereas if it's a mobile game, I mean, you just,
you can do it whenever, whenever you can do it in your free time.
Yeah. Because I mean,
I definitely felt like when I was grinding arc nights and I was over leveled for
a lot of things, even though I still couldn't beat some stages,
like the fact that cause you would do it daily because you've been conditioned
to like get your daily rewards, man.
Getting them to the point where anytime any new content ever came out,
I steamrolled it like immediately. I was like,
well that was like two hours of fun. I waited three months for that.
Content updates. I do feel like a bit like a Pavlov dog Pavlov's dog.
You know what I mean? Where it's just like, Ooh, good content, good content.
And it's just like, you can't like you can't on these games and like say,
Oh man, yeah, it's super grindy. You know, the,
the Microsoft actions are a little bit much whatever.
And then people are always, you're so quick to like defend them. And I'm like,
just admit that it's. And what they're doing is like, you,
you get a free game and then you ha you have to put up with this.
And they're like, well, I'm free to play. I don't give a.
If you're free to play. Other people are out there spending a thousand dollars.
Why is it okay if it's just your free to play, that's always the excuse.
You see the that drives me insane. And people like, as long as I'm not paying,
I'm like, what do you mean I'm free to play. I've never had any difficulties.
It's like, well good on you that you have willpower. Like.
I mean, I'm, I'm, I'm one of those people honestly free to play. No,
not free to play,
but I I'll defend the fact that you can play these games being free to play
because all you need is willpower. And you know, if
[inaudible] is the power of friendship, that's all you need. I mean,
if I wanted to, I could be free to play. I just don't want to.